as you know only the top ten candidates
in the polls were invited to participate
only the top ten in the polls but also
tonight this is true Fox is hosting a
debate for the other seven Republican
candidates who didn't make the cut
that's right yeah and ladies and
gentlemen here here is a promo for the
other debate take a look
you may have heard that only the top ten
Republican candidates and the polls were
invited to the main debate but who cares
there's another debate for the other
candidates and it's just as cool
featuring Rick Santorum Bobby Jindal
Lindsey Graham Carly femenina Rick Perry
Rick Perry with glasses and these guys
sure the main debates being held at
Cleveland state-of-the-art quicken arena
but this debate is just down the street
at the Auto Zone on featuring
state-of-the-art cardboard podiums plus
the first 25 people to attend the debate
get to participate in the debate
moderated by Coolio we still haven't
heard back each candidate will
participate in a winner-takes-all
cornhole tournament then a stirring
rendition of God bless america sung by
trent limbaugh remember these candidates
are pretty important too okay I mean
look at Rick Perry he kind of looks like
gosh Brolin who doesn't like Josh Brolin
be there at 5 p.m. for special guests
Susan Lucci Dean Cain
comedy duo PB and J
Harlem Globetrotter Meadowlark lemon the
trivago guy and music by lady Gugu shark
tanks Robert Herjavec Rick Schroder Karl
Malone Pat Sajak's D by Judge Joe Brown
matt from dora the explorer'
the green thing from the mucinex ads
brian bosworth the Chilean miners
Protege have competitive eater Kobayashi
Yoshiki formerly on Fox News that will
now be on the Golf Channel the other
debate it'll be okay
[Applause]
you